Це дорога до Херсона, точніше те, що від неї залишилося.
Протягом останніх місяців тут тривали бої.
Урешті російські війська відступили, не маючи змоги чинити
спротив постійним атакам ЗСУ по логістичним маршрутам.
Утім, перемога дісталася Україні чималою ціною.
Це село перебувало одразу за позиціями ЗСУ.
Тут складно знайти вцілілі будинки.
Ракета, що застрягла в землі, - одна з видимих небезпек.
Нерозірвані снаряди, міни одразу й не помітиш.
Дорогою до Херсона ми перетинаємо колишню лінію фронту.
Українські військові прагнуть показати, що вони не стріляють
по мирних жителях та їхніх будинках - на відміну від росіян.
Тож село Благодатне залишилося в набагато кращому стані,
ніж те, яке ми щойно залишили.
Донедавна тут була російська база.
Після стількох місяців ізоляції від зовнішнього світу
місцеві прагнуть розповісти свої історії.
І людей шикували з автоматами, що дикуни кидалися.
- І будинки обкрадали, заходили в будь-яку хату,
виносили все, що можна, усе що бачили.
- Їдеш на велосипеді - вони могли зупинити,
велосипед забрати. І що ти їм скажеш? Нічого не скажеш.
Тут уже звикли жити без електрики.
Світло зникло в селі ще 14 березня.
Кожен, у кого є безногенератор, - люди ходили, заряджали. І так виживали.
- Бензин купували.
- І то генератори ховали по сараях,
бо могли прийти забрати росіяни.
Більшість мешканців цього села не змогли призвичаїтися
до бойових дій та життя в окупації.
Нині тут залишилося лише близько чверті довоєнного населення.
Чоловік і жінка. В один будинок - його вбило,
снаряд прилетів, а потім через 40 днів жінку вбило.
В те саме місце… Хто бачив - зразу люди й виїхали.
Але виїхати могли не всі.
Люди не хотіли лишати нажите майно, боялися, що розграбують.
Господарство: кури, кози, порося.
На кого залишиш? Корови - на кого кинеш?
Що людям поробили, які виїхали?
Виводили, свиней різали, корів різали, телят різали.
Навіть уночі, в хаті, ліхтариком отак світиш і боїшся.
На вікна ковдри вішали, щоб не було видно, що в нас світло.
Ірина все життя прожила в Благодатному.
Навчалася в місцевій школі, а потім працювала тут бухгалтером-комірником.
Під час окупації росіяни перетворили школу на свою базу.
Кабінет директора використовували як житлове приміщення.
Вони ось розворочили все. Вони тут спали.
Вони робили, що хотіли. Вони зламали сейф,
у якому грошей не було.
Там лежали наші трудові книжки і просто документація.
Останні уроки тут проводилися 23 лютого.
На шкільних дошках замість прикладів чи вправ
тепер прощальні послання від росіян з нецензурною лексикою
і прокляттями на адресу українців.
Ірина розповідає, що росіяни до кінця вірили у власну пропаганду.
Одне виправдання було - ми прийшли вас звільнити.
Одне питання в мене було до них - від кого?
Від кого ти мене звільняєш? Я жила і живу нормально.
Ось я не живу зараз, поки ти тут у мене коло двору стоїш,
я не живу нормально. До цього я жила нормально.
А зараз я не живу, а існую, чекаю день до вечора,
проживу я чи не проживу? Куди той снаряд прилетить
- до мене в хату чи полетить мимо на зупинку?
Так як прилетів до сусідки і згоріла в неї хата.
Нині, після відступу росіян, люди впевнені,
що українська армія повернулася назавжди.
Утім діти, які навчалися в цих класах,
поки не поспішають повертатися.
За даними обласної військової адміністрації, на Херсонщині залишилося
менше 40 відсотків населення. Аби область повернулася
до більш-менш нормального життя, потрібно ще чимало попрацювати.
Зараз іде повна робота з розмінування, максимально.
Усі служби працюють у цьому напрямку - і наші військові,
і ДСНС, і інші фахівці, і поліцейські - усі, хто має можливість.
По-друге, війна ж триває, вона не закінчилася.
У нас вчора загинули наші побратими, вчора.
Ми вже ведемо бойові дії далі, у нас уже нові позиції.
У самому Херсоні теж постійно чути, що війна досі поруч.
Надто на узбережжі Дніпра.
Останніми днями росіяни регулярно обстрілюють
цивільну інфраструктуру в місті з артилерії.
Перший день, коли пішли, вони, звісно, боялися стріляти, мабуть.
А зараз не завжди зрозуміло, звідки стріляють,
а в інші рази чутно, що звідти. Десь летить, а там вибухає…
Уже чуємо, розуміємо, де розмінування - це просто вибух, один бабах.
Це десь розміновують в області.
Чутно, як звідти виліт - там приліт.
Чуємо і розуміємо, коли звідти виліт, там приліт.
Попереду на регіон чекає непроста зима.
Відступаючи, росіяни знищили комунальну інфраструктуру.
Тим не менше чимало херсонців певні:
пережили окупацію, не злякаються і морозів.